you had the
viral situation with russ that went down
and i hated to see that because i'm cool
with russ and i'm cool with you and i
feel like you're
one of the most brightest energies in
hip-hop
i really don't and i wasn't privy to
whatever
had been said prior but i was just like
yo you're like who [ __ ] hates you
no i mean just him right it really it
so i don't know what happened like was
there some sort of like
remarks made that like led up to that
because yeah i mentioned him in a song
and he didn't like it
um and it took a while because i was so
i was so mad at the fact that
not only did i in my mind not diss him
i never was trying to diss him but
uh i told him about it i dm'd him
beforehand
someone comes out i don't he leaves me
on red and then the first time i see him
i don't even really know him or
how how he looks or nothing i turn
around he's 20
20 [ __ ] [ __ ] after he snaked
me
and i just thought that was wild as like
a [ __ ] as rich as he is
with his network and ability right he
could have came at me different
especially
since he knew like it's no way you
planned that because he planned
he was the headline a headliner of that
festival and he planned
to to see me and have me jump because he
was there early i was one of the openers
right i mean samino was just going was
mid day i wasn't open it was midday but
still
it wasn't the headliner you know what
i'm saying uh
i feel like he could have went about
that way different but he didn't and he
and he chose that route
but at the same time you know as a
grown-ass man i did speak on him
yeah you know he did look at it as i
spoke on him and now he
he always says like you can't tell me
how to uh react to
and i think at that time everyone was
was just
it was like he was getting a lot of i
wasn't trying to down him
i actually had followed him on twitter
and i i thought that russ's
and i still do i think it's really
interesting how some people could have
so much
garner so much success in the industry
and how they navigate
but still not be accepted by the culture
but they
are clearly eating from it and feeding
some things to it
right um so that's what the bar was
about
but he took it as disrespect and
responded accordingly
i can't be mad at uh how he feel about
it
i'm obviously not happy with the outcome
right right
i mean but your intention was not
malicious with with the mention
yeah i don't even know him right right
nothing outright diss nobody
was there ever any uh correspondence
with you guys after that
or is it just kind of what it is what it
is keep it moving yeah
it's over it was never no correspondence
about nothing